many homeowners are lining up this week
to pay their property taxes early the
IRS says that some 2018 taxes paid
before December 31st can be deducted on
this year's return that's good news for
people affected by a ten thousand dollar
limit on state and local tax deductions
that begins on January 1st Jan Crawford
is at the Government Center in Fairfax
Virginia outside Washington with more
Jan good morning well good morning so
here in Virginia about 40 percent of
taxpayers took state and local
deductions in 2015 on average it was
about $1,300 more than what the upcoming
new limit will allow so here and across
the country
taxpayers tried to get a little
jumpstart on their taxes by paying them
a bit early early from Illinois to New
York I can do some of it now but I
really wish I didn't have to and
Massachusetts time we heard of prepaid
taxing can I do it with a credit card
you are all set taxpayers lined up by
the thousands to repay their property
taxes you can see and we're not the only
ones who think this is probably Laura's
glucose and his wife Susan braved long
lines Wednesday in Fairfax County
Virginia hoping to deduct their 2018
taxes a bit early accountant said if you
can afford them pay them and we can
afford it so we're paying them the
crowds lining up the week after
Christmas have been more than ten times
what the suburban Washington DC office
normally sees I've been this building
for 25 years and I have never seen the
turnout for this type of event so it's
unprecedented in 2015 more than 44
million tax returns nationwide took
advantage of the state and local tax
deduction and in 19 states in the
District of Columbia the average
deduction was over next year's $10,000
cap it'll certainly have an impact on
millions of people listen but Atlanta
tax expert Andrew Poulos says the IRS
has now clarified that estimated
property taxes that have not been
assessed are not deductible in 2017
how the agency enforces that is
uncertain so it's kind of a a take the
deduction and
that you may not get challenged but if
you do you have to be prepared for the
ramifications
now that warning yesterday from the IRS
could mean that some homeowners who go
ahead and pay all those 2018 property
tax deductions could face an audit the
IRS says it's going to challenge and
disallow any of the deductions if the
home wasn't assessed by the end of this
year
Vlad all right Jan thank you very much